dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here when we
are talking about deep learning we are
talking about neural networks that have
tens sometimes hundreds of layers and
hundreds of neurons within these layers
this is an enormous number of parameters
to train and clearly there should be
some redundancy some duplication in the
information with him this paper is
trying to throw out many of these
neurons of the network without affecting
its accuracy too much this process which
are called pruning and it helps creating
neural networks that are faster and
smaller the accuracy term I used
typically means a score and a
classification task in other words how
good this learning algorithm is in
telling what an image or video depicts
this particular technique is specialized
for pruning convolutional neural
networks where the neurons are endowed
with a small receptive field and are
better suited for images these neurons
are also commonly referred to as filters
so here we have to provide a good
mathematical definition of a proper
pruning the authors proposed a
definition where we can specify a
maximum accuracy drop that we deemed to
be acceptable which will be denoted with
the letter B in a moment and the goal is
to prune as many filters as we can
without going over the specified
accuracy loss budget the pruning process
is controlled by an accuracy and
efficiency term and the goal is to have
some sort of balance between the two to
get a more visual understanding of what
is happening here the filters you see
outlined with the red border are kept by
the algorithm and the rest are discarded
as you can see the algorithm is not as
trivial as many previous approaches that
just prune away filters with weaker
responses here you see the table with
the B numbers initial tests reveal that
around 1/4 of the filters can be pruned
with an accuracy loss of 0.3% and with a
higher B we can prune more than 75% of
the filters with a loss of around 3%
this is incredible image segmentation
tasks are about finding the regions that
different objects inhabit interestingly
when trying the pruning for
this task it not only introduces a
minimal loss of accuracy in some cases
the proven version of the neural network
performs even better how cool is that
and of course the best part is that we
can choose a trade-off that is
appropriate for our application for
instance if we are looking for a light
cleanup we can use the first option at a
minimal penalty or if we wish to have a
tiny tiny neural network that can run on
a mobile device we can look for the more
heavy-handed approach by sacrificing
just a tiny bit more accuracy and we
have everything in between there is
plenty more validation for the method in
the paper make sure to have a look it is
really great to see that new research
works make neural networks not only more
powerful over time but there are efforts
in making them smaller and more
efficient at the same time great news
indeed thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]